IT'S TIME TO PLAY OKCREEPY.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
VALENTINE'S DAY IS ON FRIDAY
AND IF YOU'RE SINGLE, YOU'RE
PROBABLY ON OKCUPID RIGHT NOW.
BUT THERE ARE A LOT OF WEIRDOS
OUT THERE WHO EAGERLY WANT TO
PUT THINGS IN YOU.
SO WE'RE GOING TO SHOW YOU AN
EXCERPT FROM A UNIQUE OKCUPID
PROFILE AND FOR 250 POINTS,
YOU FINISH THE SENTENCE.
HERE IS THE FIRST ONE.
"I LOVE TO COLLECT" BLANK.
YES, APARNA.
>> MY THOUGHTS, SO JUST GIVE ME
A SECOND.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: I WILL GIVE YOU
POINTS FOR THAT.
LET'S FIND OUT WHAT HE LIKES TO
COLLECT.
"ANGEL STUFF AND LIZARD FOBS
AND BOOKS 'ECT'."
I THINK HE MEANS ET CETERA OR
THIS IS SHORT FOR ECTOPLASM.
(LAUGHTER)
>> THIS DUDE'S COOL, I LIKE THIS
GUY.
>> Chris: ALL RIGHT, NEXT ONE.
"I'M REALLY GOOD AT...
(AUDIENCE REACTS)
...SEX, FOREPLAY AND GENTLE
STROKING.
(LAUGHTER)
I AM GREAT AT MAKING" BLANK.
RON FUNCHES?
>> I AM GREAT AT MAKING RON
FUNCHES QUESTION HIS SEXUALITY.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: POINTS.
LET'S FIND OUT WHAT HE'S REALLY
GREAT AT.
HE'S REALLY GREAT AT "MY OWN
JELLY BEANS."
(LAUGHTER)
HE MAKES HIS OWN JELLY BEANS.
RON, DID THIS JUST ENTICE YOU
EVEN FURTHER?
>> YES.
>> Chris: RON IS WAY MORE ON
BOARD NOW THAN SECOND AGO.
>> IF I COULD JUST GET A
MATCHING ONE OF THOSE SHIRTS,
WE'RE ON BOARD!
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: ALL RIGHT, "THE SIX
THINGS I COULD NEVER DO WITHOUT:
1) WAXING
2) SEX
3) DANCING AND--
RON?
(LAUGHTER)
YOU'RE SO DELIGHTED BY THIS GAME
AND WATCHING YOU BE DELIGHTED
MAKES ME DELIGHTED.
>> OKAY, 4) ERYKAH BADU.
(LAUGHTER)
5) ANIME.
6) LOOSE WORK UNIFORM POLICIES.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: YES, I'LL GIVE YOU
POINTS FOR THAT.
BRAUNGER, YOU WANT TO TAKE A
CRACK AT IT?
>> YEAH, I WOULD SAY A GUN,
A TASER AND THE BOARD GAME
"SORRY."
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: LET'S FIND OUT WHAT
THE FOUR, FIVE AND SIX ARE.
4) ANAL BLEACHING
5) CHIPOTLE
6) MORGAN FREEMAN.
>> YES!